the return of the Dilophosaurus um
Maureen Malcolm amazing are just some of
the scenes we never got to see in
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm revealing the top deleted
scenes from Jurassic world 2 plus
explaining scenes that were sent to the
graphic violence spoilers ahead for the
movie so take care if you haven't seen
it yet
although fallen Kingdom features more
dinosaurs than ever there's one fan
favorite that ended up deleted from the
final film director Jo Bojana revealed a
scene with a couple of Dilophosaurus was
cut from the movie the dilo first
appeared in the original Jurassic Park
and let's face it who can forget that
scene where Dennis Nedry gets his
comeuppance it seems like the
Dilophosaurus was supposed to appear in
fallen kingdoms opening scene with a guy
in the Yellow Jacket who was operating
the mosasaur gate was startled by a
rustling in the bushes along with a
little chirp reminiscent to the dilo in
the first movie the Mercs yellowjacket
would also have made the moment a nice
callback to Nedry scene in Jurassic Park
the Raptor chaser Twitter account
actually snapped some photos of a dino
model at the Pinewood Workshop for the
film
I suspect the dialers were cut to make
the opening scene tighter keep the
tension racked up and maintain the focus
on the t-rex about to appear it's still
a shame we never got to see this rather
colorful and interesting dino again in
the flesh especially after the hologram
tease at the Visitor Centre in Jurassic
world I don't know if any were taken off
the island as I didn't see any at
Lockwood Manor but given that woo has
collected samples of a variety of dinos
it's not impossible that we'll see Ned
Rees killer return in Jurassic world 3
new to the Jurassic franchises Daniella
Pineda Zia the paleo vet who works with
Clara and Franklin at the dinosaur
protection group and there's an
interesting bit of backstory about Zia
that ended up cut from the movie Panetta
revealed that she filmed a scene before
the main action on the island begins
where she's talking to Owen and says
yeah squirt your good bone structure
tall muscles
I don't date men if I did it would be
you it would gross me out but I do it
Piniella says the scene wasn't relevant
to the overall story so is chopped as
the movie was running long and it's also
possible it was cut because it didn't
feel very funny in the Edit while the
line feels like a potentially
easy way for the screenwriters to point
out the her characters lesbian the
decision to delete it is just the latest
example of what seems to be part of a
trend in Hollywood blockbusters whether
reveal of an lgbtq+ character
sexualities cut from the final movie for
example valkyries bisexuality and Taika
Waititi thor ragnarok and land those
pansexuality and solo a Star Wars story
the initial kiss of Jurassic world 2 was
about two and three-quarter hours long
so with the final time clocking in at
around two hours and eight minutes
there's more than half an hour of
footage we never got to see by owner has
said that right now there are no plans
to release any deleted or alternate
scenes on the blu-ray or DVD which will
doubtless disappoint many fans however
I've done a bit of detective work and
trawl through the official trailers TV
spots and behind-the-scenes footage for
clues on what else needs for being cut
from fallen Kingdom first up is Ian
Malcolm's line hey I'm talking about
dinosaurs again and they also seem to
have deleted Malcolm's classic line
which he said in a teaser trailer during
the Senate committee hearing life finds
away maybe they cut this as they felt it
was too on-the-nose but personally I
would have loved to have heard him say
this again in the film Owen also had a
couple of lines and the trailers that
were dropped from the final movie this
is gonna be awesome
Owen ventriloquist stopper you love a
dummy the dummy line should have been
included because it would have made a
Wynn's ventriloquist question declare in
the movie funnier and less random
there's a deleted jump-scare in the
island control room when Franklin tries
to fix a light bulb fixed it
fixing thanks and I don't recall seeing
this footage of Maisie playing with
dinosaur toys in Lockwood Manor in the
movie this would have been additional
foreshadowing of the reveal that
Benjamin Lockwood had used the dinosaur
genetic cloning technology he developed
with John Hammond to create Maisy as a
clone of his dead daughter this camera
angle and shot of the Carnotaurus
running at the gyrosphere wasn't in the
movie but there was an alternate take
used of the car no readying itself to
attack before Rexy steps in and saves
the day these trucks driving past the
Dino skeleton didn't make it either and
I don't think we saw this underwater
shot of the mater saw opening its eye
let me know if you spotted any other
clips that weren't in the movie the
Jurassic films have always been pretty
intense monster movies however they've
always been accessible to a fairly wide
audience
age-wise for fallen Kingdom though it
appears that some countries have
actually censored a number of the more
violent scenes in the movie for example
the indie rap de scene where the Dino
rips off Ted Levine's arm was reportedly
censored in Italy in Korea other scenes
that have apparently been banned at the
scene of t-rex eating the goat when
she's moved into the basement at
Lockwood manner also censored for some
is the moment where the villainous Eli
Mills gets ripped in half by t-rex and
Carnotaurus and even t-rex his final
roar in front of the line has reportedly
been cut in some countries now do you
think the dialogue for Soros should have
been in the film and there any other
deleted scenes you wish had been
included I'd let the yield thoughts in
the comments below
tap left to watch my fallen Kingdom
ending and post credit scene explained
plus Jurassic world 3 theory and tap
right for my full movie deleted scenes
playlists congratulations to my solo
giveaway winner send me an email from my
channels about page or tweet me so I can
send you the prize thanks for watching
and see you next time you pick a movie
lovers